good morning John it's Tuesday I am
right now on the set of Wil Wheaton's
tabletop RPG show I have been having an
amazing time here going on adventures
and a custom designed campaign that will
made for me Yuri Lowenthal Laura Bailey
and Alison Haislip John I've been
discovering the weirdnesses of snapchat
and I decided to do a question video
today and the questions are all going to
come from snapchat what did you play
with wheels we've been playing a brand
new RPG that did not exist before but
it's called Titans grave the ashes of
volcanic sort of sci-fi mixed with
fantasy world if you could remove an
element from the periodic table which
one would you choose I assume were
talking about removing an element of the
periodic table from the world because he
can't just remove an element from the
periodic table it doesn't do anything
it's just less knowledge that we have
then I think I'd probably pick one of
the more dangerous ones like if we had
less plutonium in the world don't know
that that would be a bad thing
what is your songwriting process usually
I started like one good line that I
really love that has really great rhythm
and then I can kind of start a melody
around if I love that line enough then
it gives me the desire to work hard to
create a song around it so it's more how
do I inspire myself to want to write a
song than how do I actually write the
song because if I if I want it bad
enough I feel like it's just gonna
happen how are you liking snapchat so
far that's a lovely elephant up shot is
weird I don't think that I use it the
way that most people use it because I
you know I already have an audience and
so I'm kind of just trying to make
people laugh and have a good time and
it's a really great format for that
because I don't have to worry about the
things being like part of my permanent
record I feel more free to just mess
around and be dumb which is important to
me
favorite National Park gonna go with
yellow oh I kicked dye back box sorry
I'm gonna go with Yellowstone National
Park cuz it is weird it is an amazing
magical place it's got a lot of
geological weirdness and biological
weirdness how cute is my banana monkey
your banana monkey is cute I am worried
about where its legs are who do you
normally play as on Mario Kart I'm a
Donkey Kong man Mario Kart and Smash
Brothers I just need the extra beef not
a finesse player what's your favorite
kitchen utensil that is a weird question
maybe a colander why do dogs get a
booger
two dogs get eye boogers for the same
reason we do there's stuff that comes
out of your eye it's usually it's
dissolved in your tears
it's called rune and it contains all
kinds of stuff you probably don't to
know about like blood cells and
epithelial cells and and also mucus when
the water leaves mucus the stuff it
leaves behind is the mutant compounds
which are proteins which are sort of
gummy and gross dogs have just as much
of that stuff as we do I think most
mammals or all mammals even get get that
get that going on best by employees love
scishow apparently that's not a question
but thank you for letting me know that's
cool lasagna cupcakes yeah also not a
question if there are two dogs and one
cat how many fish are there as far as I
could tell the number of dogs and cats
has no bearing on the number of fish why
haven't you done a dance video while
[Music]
done I'm really excited about this show
to me coming out in June so it's gonna
be well before everybody gets to see it
but we have been having amazing time
with these little dice and I'm excited
to share it with all of you John I'll
see you on Tuesday